so I hate to have to break it to you today
and just start the show on such a negative
note, especially to my progressive [inaudible]
audience members. But unless something changes
with a high likelihood, Donald Trump is very
rapidly barreling towards reelection in 2020
and this is why I've been very careful not
to make any statements when I report about,
Oh, you know, Georgia could conceivably be
in play, Texas could conceivably be in play.
Uh, there are a lot of uh, ifs, ands and buts
attached to that and before we get into the
issues based components of my commentary today,
let's just deal with the math quickly because
there are people who are just putting way
too much confidence in the polling data that
shows Trump not doing well in North Carolina
and Georgia and Texas and Trump's approval
rating is tanking. And then there are also
people who just don't believe me when I say
that Donald Trump can get reelected even despite
a very low approval rating. The reality is
that what we saw in 2004 is the case.
Anytime you're trying to unseat an incumbent
president, which is, it's really difficult.
Donald Trump, uh, certainly very different
than George W. Bush in many ways, but as difficult
as it was to remove Bush in 2004, ultimately
not being removed. Of course, even someone
as malignantly ignorant and acutely narcissistic
as Donald Trump will be difficult to remove.
Now from a mathematical perspective, when
half the country doesn't vote and you have
an electoral college system, that systemically
favors republicans in all of the ways that
we've talked about before, Donald Trump's
36 or 38 or 40% approval rating can easily
get him re-elected. Now, I've said before,
you can construct the math such that it's
possible to get reelected even with 27% approval,
and it's true. But if you disagree with me
about that or you think it's an exaggeration,
it's not even worth arguing about because
Trump's approval rating isn't that low and
there's no indication it's going to go that
low.
So with the math piece out of the way, let's
look at what Democrats are doing so far. Bearing
in mind that we're still in the pre-primary
phase. Democrats need to run good campaigns
with progressive ideas that are popular, of
course, but Democrats also need to at least
somewhat appeal to red state voters and moderates
in Purple States on the issues that clearly
matter right now. As I've said before, as
a strategy get out, the vote is much more
powerful than arguing with Trumpists, but
it still makes sense to at least stake out
positions, generally speaking, that will be
reasonable to some fraction of those moderate
Republican voters. There's unnecessary disclaimer
here. I'm being strategic here. I'm not talking
about what I like and what my politics are.
I'm talking about winning 2020 think about
immigration first. It's disgusting what's
happening at the border. It's a real humanitarian
crisis, but most of the conversations that
Democratic candidates are having are ridiculous
and debate moderators are hugely to blame
for this.
As I've talked about before, what's happening
with the discussion around deportations on
the right is an absolute fantasy, right? I
mean, we're not going to deport 12 million
people who are in the United States illegally,
nor would we want to deport the 12 million
people that are in the United States illegally.
If people are committing violent crimes and
they're here illegally. Okay, they're, now
you're talking about people that it makes
sense to deport. But the reality is that there
are multiple industries that depend on these
undocumented immigrants, including agriculture,
including the restaurant industry. And they're
a hugely positive influence on our society,
both economically and culturally from a a,
any number of standpoints from an American
dream standpoint, from a work ethic standpoint,
and basically every way that we can imagine.
Almost all of these undocumented immigrants
are actually a positive force here in the
United States. At the same time, democrats
need to throw a bone to centrist and republican
voters around the need to have a defensible
border, a defended border.
I've already debunked the idea of the wall
endless times and Democrats don't need to,
you know, pretend to be aggressive neo-cons
on the wall or even dabble with the xenophobic
or racist stuff, but something needs to be
done to just merely get on the record to Republican
voters that Democratic candidates understand
the concerns. There will be a defensible border
and no one is advocating for open borders
because they're going to try to smear all
the Democratic candidates as being in favor
of open borders when of course, that's not
the case. It should just be made clear that
no one is advocating for open borders because
that's the truth, but a little more is going
to need to be done and said if we don't want
to have the exact repetition of the 2016 election,
this isn't controversial, right? Every country
in the world that is an interesting and appealing
place for people to come to from other countries
is going to have a defended border.
This wouldn't change under a Democratic president.
Let's just like go 5% further in making that
clear, but like I've said before, we end up
with all of this, you know, raise your hands
if you'd give undocumented immigrants healthcare,
even if that's a morally correct position
to take. It's a losing position if that becomes
the focus in the national election and Democrats
need to make damn sure that that doesn't actually
become the focus no matter what debate moderators
are going to try to do. Okay. Let's talk about
farmers and the Midwest, which we've been
talking about for months. At this point in
time. You have farmers in the Midwest who
are aware that it's Donald Trump's tariffs
that have been a disaster for them, but saying,
I will reverse the tariffs as many Democratic
candidates have been saying, is not going
to convince a lifelong Midwestern Republican
to vote for a Democrat.
And I've said this before, when we hear about
all of these Trump voters in the Midwest who
are angry with Trump or disapprove of Trump,
or are farmers and recognize that Trump has
ruining their businesses, that doesn't mean
that you're going to go out and vote for a
Democrat in November of 2020 lifelong Republicans
who don't approve of Trump, aren't necessarily
voting for Joe Biden or Bernie Sanders or
Elizabeth Warren. So something more needs
to be done there. And it generally relates
to the economic anxieties of Middle America
that Hillary Clinton didn't do a good job
of addressing in an appropriate enough way.
This is just the reality. I'm not saying the
narrative about disadvantaged white people
is based in any reality. It's ridiculous.
What I am saying is that without addressing
some of these issues in a smart way, Trump
gets reelected period. This gets me to the
distraction attempts that have been very successful
by the right when Donald Trump generates a
firestorm around whether this or that person
is racist or whether a comment was racist
or whatever.
These are important issues, but they are not
issues that are going to get swing state voters
to abandon Donald Trump or motivate anyone
to get out and vote. If they see an endless
focus and debate over whether this or that
comment was racist as an example. Now I know
that there are people on the left who won't
like this, but it's just the reality and then
unfortunately I spoke a year ago about my
desire for this not to happen. Democrats and
their supporters are starting to slam each
other in a way that could be self-destructive
and just help Donald Trump. We are seeing,
I'm going in no particular order here. We're
seeing a rise of a no Biden, no way contingent,
and I agree that Joe Biden is not a progressive,
but I also remember all those people who said
in 2016 who cares? Hillary would be the same
as Trump, and of course they couldn't have
been more wrong.
Look at the Supreme Court. Look at the 25%
of a judges that Donald Trump has appointed
and we're reminded every day that and the
geopolitical belligerence and now trying to
collude with it, forcing collusion with another
country, Ukraine, we'll talk about that later,
could not have been more different from Hillary
Clinton, so that's a concern. Then we have
the growing group of Bernie supporters focusing
their ire on Elizabeth Warren, even mass unsubscribing
from my youtube channel last week when I pointed
out, hey, in 60% of recent polls, Warren has
surpassed Bernie into second place. This group
claiming Warren is a tool of the establishment
to to appear progressive and I'm a shill merely
for mentioning poll results. Bernie and Warren
are not the same. That's clear, but that is
another contingent that is potentially self-destructive
and it's getting to the point where it could
be damaging. In the general election, the
Tulsi people, I've already talked about, Andrew
Yang's followers, who although relatively
small mathematically are getting extremely
angry with just like everything, every, anything
that happens there absolutely furious about.
Then you've got Biden supporters who are falling
for the often repeated right wing talking
points about Bernie and Warren are extreme.
They are radical. They're too far left. They're
even talking about the term socialism that's
there. There's a contingent of Biden's supporters.
That's terrible. This is the type of stuff
that will propel Donald Trump to reelection
because it feeds narratives that are not useful
to the left, so I'm not saying this because
I'm looking to attack a particular candidate
or the supporters of a particular candidate.
This isn't even about particular candidates.
This is merely pragmatism. We saw what happened
in 2016 and unless we prevent these things
I'm mentioning from getting completely out
of control, it's going to happen again and
we'll have four more years of Trump. Now,
there are people in the audience who would
rather have four more years of Trump. Then
whoever you don't like from the Democratic
primary, right?
There are people who would say, burn it all
down, let Trump do whatever he wants to do
because it's better than having whoever it
is that's running in the Democratic primary.
I just disagree with that as a strategy. I
think that the more we look at history, the
more we realize that what has worked historically
is not uh, foregoing small changes we could
make right now with the idea of eventually
burning it all down and building it back up
in a perfect image of what is perfectly aligned
with our political ideology. That's not the
way it's worked in the last however many,
however, however many years you consider to
be modern politics. That's simply not a strategy
that's worked. So I'm open to having my mind
change. If you think you can convince me that
the let Trump have another four years, burn
it all down and then we'll be in a much better
position for 2020 for mentality. If you want
to try to convince me of that, I'm more than
open to hearing from you, but it's not something
that I see backed by history. It's not something
I see backed by logic and it's not something
that seems like the right approach. Let me
know what you think. I'm open to having my
mind changed about all of this, but I am increasingly
concerned because I don't want to see another
four years of Donald Trump. Yeah, I know it'd
be great for the show, but I care about the
country even more than that.
Uh, and I want to hear it from you. If you
disagree with me, I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show